bonjour à tous bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro de reporter direction aujourd'hui
la transnistrie un petit territoire de
seulement quatre mille kilomètres carrés
que la guerre en ukraine vient placer
sous les projecteurs cette enclave
séparatiste a coincé entre la moldavie
et l'ukraine a déclaré unilatéralement
son indépendance en 1990 à l'éclatement
de l'union soviétique une enclave qui a
toujours était stratégique pour la
russie et qu'il est d'autant plus
aujourd'hui du fait de sa proximité avec
odessa la grande ville portuaire
ukrainienne de la mer noire c'est un
pays on va le voir tiraillée entre l'est
et l'ouest entre l'attachement à moscou
et l'ancrage géographiques européens
lauriane dervault cours bonjour bonjour
vous y êtes rendus pour france 24 mais
avant les attaques qui ont eu lieu fin
avril début mai oui en effet c'est vrai
qu'il ya eu des attaques fin avril qu'on
replace est ce territoire au coeur à la
une de l'actualité c'est un territoire
qui est très peu connu très peu de
personnes connaissaient la transnistrie
et sa position géographique vous l'avez
dit est très stratégique la question que
je me suis posée avant de partir c'est
que veut son gouvernement soit il un
rattachement à la russie que veulent ses
habitants et je pense que la guerre en
ukraine a changé d esprit dans cette
partie du monde lauriane dherbecourt
vous restez avec nous transnistrie à la
merci des puissances et donc votre
reportage on le regarde et on vous
retrouve tout de suite après
[Musique]
allez venez les gars vos tanks
c'est un circuit touristique pas comme
les autres pour un pays pas comme les
autres
est le temps qu est placé ici chez nous
depuis 1968
depuis 2011 andrei smolenski organise
des soviets tour pour les rares
touristes qui viennent en transnistrie
on est là pour apprendre un peu plus sur
cet endroit au delà des peu de chose que
l'on voit sur internet sur ce pays qui
n'existe pas
la transnistrie
cette petite enclave séparatiste coincé
entre la moldavie et l'ukraine a déclaré
son indépendance en 1990
malgré ses multiples demandes elle n'a
jamais été reconnue par la communauté
internationale
elle fonctionne pourtant comme un état
ici vous pouvez voir le parlement et le
siège du gouvernement qui date de 1983
la statue de lenine de 1987 le drapeau
de la transnistrie et celui de la russie
dès qu'on franchit la frontière on se
rend compte que si c'est éthique
l'appareil
la langue est différente
ce n'est pas le même style de vie
ici la vie semble figée dans le passé
soviétique
dans les grandes villes les vestiges de
l'urss sont visibles à chaque coin de
rue
pour les 470 mille habitants russophones
du pays l'histoire tient une place bien
particulière
au delà de la lutte contre l'allemagne
nazie c'est surtout la guerre
séparatiste avec la moldavie en 1992 qui
a marqué les esprits
un conflit de quelques semaines à peine
mais plusieurs milliers de morts honoré
chaque année sur cette place
la sécurité de la transnistrie est
toujours assurée par 1500 soldats russes
le petit état essaie malgré tout
d'exister par lui même
le territoire commerce avec le monde
entier mais toutes ces productions
doivent obligatoirement être étiqueté
comme produit moldave et non
transnistrien
une injustice selon vitali igniatieff le
ministre des affaires étrangères
actuellement la moldavie bloc
l'approvisionnement en médicaments en
nourriture et en engrais pour nos
producteurs agricoles ce sont des
éléments du blocus est le principal
obstacle qui nous empêche de vivre et de
nous développer librement
et à son existence officielle ses
habitants pourtant développé un fort
sentiment patriotique
sacha 36 ans est vigile dans un
restaurant comme beaucoup il vit dans un
quartier héritées de l'époque soviétique
de très nombreuses nationalités agite
ici russe moldave l'ukrainien bulgare
tout le monde
c'est une république aux multiples
nationalités
maman on est à la maison vous êtes enfin
rentrer
tous les soirs depuis le début de la
guerre en ukraine sacha s'installe
devant vichy à wana la première chaîne
publique russe où les présentateurs
affiche sans ambiguïté leur soutien la
politique de vladimir poutine
la guerre toujours la guerre en ukraine
ça ne s'arrête pas une chose
c'est terrible
tout le monde a des parents des
connaissances et des proches la base
c'est donc un sujet très émouvant que je
suis régulièrement
une émotion alimenter h24 par les médias
officiels russes
quand on bat les choses si vous me
demandez comment j'aimerais que le
problème soit résolu
je souhaite la paix
l'harmonie
enfin que la république moldave de
transnistrie deviennent indépendantes
dans le meilleur des cas qu'elle fasse
partie de la fédération de russie
je vois ça comme ça
tout le monde ici souhaite la fin de la
guerre pro russe majoritairement les
transnistrien n'ont pourtant pas tous
choisi le camp de moscou
bender la deuxième ville du pays
[Musique]
alexander est professeur de
mathématiques
depuis le début du conflit cet opposant
de vladimir poutine est très actif sur
les réseaux sociaux
j'aime vraiment cette
si alexander relaie les informations sur
la guerre en ukraine c'est dans un but
bien précis
si
dans notre région tout le monde est
tourné vers la fédération de russie
et
la chine souhaitent tout le monde
pensait et j'ai également pu pendant
longtemps que la russie prenait soin de
nous
parce que je tiens beaucoup de personnes
ne regarde que les chaînes d'information
russie et ont une vision du monde biaisé
on l'a droguée un quartier
mais beaucoup de gens ne veulent pas
accepter cette réalité
il le faisait leur vision du monde
s'effondrerait
c'est très douloureux je le comprends
pas dit
alexander reste néanmoins confiant son
gouvernement il le croit sera trouvé sa
voie sans s'impliquer dans la guerre
d'autres ont perdu cet espoir et
envisage de fuir pour rejoindre ce qu'il
considère comme la mère patrie
[Musique]
tatiana est professeur d'anglais à 46
ans elle n'a jamais quitté son quartier
en 1992 alors adolescente elle a vu du
haut de son immeuble les moldaves
attaquer oui 11 on a vu je ne sais pas
comment ça s'appelle en anglais
depuis la droite vers la gauche verte
et rose
ça ne s'est pas passé pendant qu'une
nuit puis deux puis trois et on a vécu
dans cette
affaire fit for free main pendant trois
mois joué trois mois des bombes des
bombes des bombes
[Musique]
hors de question pour tatiana de revivre
ce cauchemar
[Musique]
j'ai reçu un message
très étrange et horrible
je vais vous traduis
salue les bâtards quelque chose comme ça
mon nom est alexander alexandre au ski
je suis un nationaliste moldave j'ai
posé des bombes sous vos écoles et je
vais vous en envoyer aussi
des
éléments revanche
info ou intox
ce type de message nourrit la peur de
tatiana elle a décidé de vendre
l'appartement de famille pour rejoindre
saint pétersbourg où vivent déjà sa
fille aînée
ce sont les dernières affaires que nous
devons emballé nous emballons à la va
vite car nous n'avons plus de temps
à regarder c'est le passeport de ma mère
est utile est encore valable vous pouvez
voir c'est celui de l'urss passe pocho
chistine elle utilise encore il est
valable seulement en transnistrie en
moldavie juste dans ces pays nous sommes
le dernier pays soviétiques et le monde
on est toujours un pays communiste
[Applaudissements]
tatiana est fier de son éducation
soviétique
sa mère galina professeur de français se
sent elle trahi par la russie depuis
l'invasion de l'ukraine
[Musique]
moi j'en ai assez de la guerre
j'aimais toujours poutine je les
respecte et je le considérais très
intelligent mais voilà cette idée que
l'ennemi se trouve non l'om de nouveaux
d'hier
sama mathieu et gilles ne suis pas
contre eux les russes je suis contre la
mort mais ce sont les russes qui feront
pâlir les gens oui
des citoyens partagés sur les
responsabilités du conflit
un pays tiraillé entre l'est et l'ouest
la transnistrie a récemment été accusée
de servir de base arrière aux militaires
russes son gouvernement sont des changes
aujourd'hui le petit territoire refuse
de prendre part à la guerre mais pour
combien de temps encore
peu après notre départ la déclaration
d'un général russe a ravivé les tensions
dans la région
ce haut gradé a clairement affiché les
ambitions de moscou conquérir tout le
sud de l'ukraine pour permettre à
l'armée russe de faire la jonction avec
la transnistrie
[Musique]
quelques jours après cette sortie
belliqueuse
plusieurs attaques non revendiquées ont
été menées en transnistrie contre un
bâtiment officiel ou encore des tours de
radio russe
après ces événements nous avons voulu
savoir ce qu'il était advenu des
personnes que nous avions rencontré
[Musique]
sacha le vigile n'a pas encore été
mobilisés mais il suit l'évolution de la
situation avec une certaine inquiétude
et se prépare au pire
et bien si les hostilités commencent
réellement on devra faire quelque chose
nous avons une petite armée nous nous
défendrons avec nos propres forces
nous nous défendrons aussi longtemps que
nous pourrons je pense que ça se passera
comme cela nous espérons recevoir l'aide
de la russie bien sûr on verra je
voudrais croire aux meilleurs mais
personne n'abandonne ras la transnistrie
les habitants ne l'accepterons pas
[Musique]
quant à tatiana ses enfants et sa mère
galina ils ont quitté la transnistrie
[Musique]
je suis partagé car d'un côté nous
sommes très tristes d'avoir dû quitter
notre maison mais nous sommes aussi très
heureuse de l'avoir fait car cela
faisait trois jours que nous tentions de
le faire
le temps de préparer le grand voyage
vers la russie tatiana et sa famille
seront hébergés chez des amis dans le
nord de la moldavie
quelle que soit l'issue de la guerre
la transnistrie et ses habitants ne
maîtriseront sans doute pas leur destin
une histoire particulière depuis ses
débuts qui continuera de s'écrire au bon
vouloir des puissances voisines et de
leurs intérêts
[Musique]
on le voyait un dans ce reportage des
habitants de transnistrie semblent
divisés par la guerre en ukraine même si
on sent en même temps un fort désir
d'indépendance
est ce que cette indépendance est
vraiment possible lauriane politiquement
d'abord mais surtout économiquement
alors c'est vrai que c'est la grande
question qui se pose est ce que ce
territoire est il capable de s'auto
suffire par lui même on lit dans de
nombreux médias que ce territoire est
perfusé par la russie qu'il est
totalement dépendant et notamment au
niveau du gaz puisque c'est la russie
qui fournit le gaz à la moldavie et à la
transnistrie nous avons posé cette
question ministre des affaires
étrangères vitalic matthiew je vous
laisse écouter sa réponse
la réalité que la transnistrie n'achète
pas directement du gaz à la russie une
entreprise moldave l'achète par
conséquent les dettes qui existent sont
les dettes de la moldavie donc la
question du gaz doit être résolue aussi
si la transnistrie est un état
indépendant nous paieront nos dettes
mais si c'est une dette moldave qui date
depuis longtemps alors c'est la moldavie
qui devra la payer parfois été
dernièrement
alors c'est vrai que la question du gaz
est une question épineuse et montre bien
à quel point le territoire est prise en
étau entre la moldavie et la russie
c'est également un territoire qu'il ya
de nombreuses ressources qui commercent
avec l'est comme avec l'ouest on pense à
l'industrie lourde on pense aux
spiritueux ils sont connus pour leur
brandit on pense également au caviar et
d'ailleurs c'est un territoire qui
souffrent de la guerre en ukraine
puisque odessa était le principal point
de passage de tous ses produits au
niveau interne il ya quand même une
mainmise d'un gros conglomérats qui
s'appelle chérif qui viennent des
services secrets russes et qui sont
connus pour être assez proches du
pouvoir quel avenir alors pour cette
enclave séparatiste
l'avenir est incertain et tout dépendra
aussi de l'évolution de la guerre en
ukraine on pense encore une fois à
odessa qui est juste à côté du
territoire le sort de dessin est très
important pour ce territoire une chose
est sûre ce territoire réclame son
indépendance
il souhaite rester loin de la guerre
pour combien de temps l'avenir nous le
dira lauriane dherbecourt merci beaucoup
merci à vous de votre fidélité la
transnistrie à la merci des puissants un
reportage à voir et à revoir à tout
moment sur france 24 points comme sur la
page de l'émission reporter a très vite
[Musique]